all right Victoria yes Victoria where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I was technically born in L.A
but then moved down to San Diego and I
was
like three years old South San Diego so
like Imperial Beach it's right next to
the border and tell me about your family
growing up I have one older brother
um who we're two years seven months
three days apart not that we're counting
um and I got both my parents who are
still married to this day and it's been
like 36 years for them and it's just
always been the four of us how would you
describe your childhood I would describe
it as really happy
um
well
I'd say happy-ish just because I grew up
feeling depressed and anxious a lot but
outside like what was happening with me
it was a relatively happy childhood I
grew up on a street with like 12 other
kids that were all the same age and it
was great like lemonade stands tag Until
Dark like picturesque sounds great yeah
it was really nice and then I moved from
South San Diego to another part of South
San Diego which was more affluent and
things changed a lot like I was kind of
a culture shock going from like I was
like the smartest kid in school to no
longer being that like at the new place
I was living at or it was kind of like
what your culture shocking moving is
always tough for kids yeah
and how far are you in school
oh um I'm completed High School got my
bachelor's and now I'm getting my
master's program
or I'm in a master's program for
teaching
told me you had some rough patches
between then and now
yes
um so I've been hospitalized for my
bipolar disorder and depression and
anxiety there was times I wouldn't go to
school for years because like my anxiety
was too much and I couldn't just
function so I had like periods of being
like on and off of school
um not working sometimes it was really
tough it like really affects you
like the the bipolar
uh
started showing itself when oh the
bipolar disorders started showing itself
on all them High School
um I
I knew something was wrong and I didn't
know how to tell my parents that my
brother had ADHD and he was super hyper
all the time so my parents paid a lot of
attention to him
um for that reason and for me they kind
of just thought oh she's fine by herself
you know she's she's chill
um but that was really hard because I
started noting season symptoms like my
mind was always racing I was always I
was being really erratic
um really impulsive and I just had like
this really really like dark periods of
depression and then these crazy periods
like Mania and feeling fine and
everything's great and perfect and it
was really hard especially being in high
school because I didn't I didn't know
that I had bipolar disorder I didn't
find out until I was 19. and we should
have picked up on it a lot earlier
because a lot of my mom's family has
bipolar disorder my great-grandmother
had schizophrenia
so we probably should have like thought
about that my mom has clinical
depression and um we they just didn't
like pay that extra attention but I knew
something was up at a younger age I had
had anxiety since I was in like third
grade
um but I never thought like oh I'll have
I'll have uh bipolar disorder someday
how would you describe being bipolar for
those that don't know
being bipolar
it can be really fun at times but those
times are usually really damaging so
when I'm manic everything is like
beautiful and you know things are shiny
and you can do anything you want and
that's so hard when it comes crashing
down and you enter the suppressive
episode and I'm a Rapid Cycling type 1
bipolar
a person with bipolar disorder so that
means that I get
oh man I could have huge moon shifts in
one day which is really wild
um and it's hard to see on top of that
and you can go from really erratic to so
depressed you don't want to move and
it's pretty severe in that it could
happen so often in just one day or in a
very short period of time because a lot
of people are type two so it like
spreads out for longer periods of time
for them
or they might have short Mania and a
long depression so having this like
constant roller coaster of emotions is
exhausting and it just you feel pretty
defeated after a while
but I try and like maintain a really
positive point of view on it I like I
think about like okay this isn't
something that I chose to have this is
something that was that just happened
it's not my fault
but you still feel like this kind of
weird guilt of being like oh [ __ ] I have
like this you know mental illness and
it's going to affect me the rest of my
life and it affects the people I love
and my family and stuff so you feel like
a little weird sense of guilt for having
it even though it's like out of your
control so it's
it's a struggle the depressive episodes
the highs
um thankfully I'm like more stable now
because after I went to the mental
hospital I met this doctor and he asked
me like is your family have bipolar
disorder I was like yeah are some of
your are they stable
and I was like yeah they're some of them
are really good what do they take and I
told them medication and they said um
you know what you have similar chemistry
we're just going to try that and that
like totally saved my life beforehand I
couldn't handle being in a relationship
having a job going to school and now I
feel like I could like function more
I feel like okay I can I can manage life
and I could live it and I don't feel
like so constantly
overwhelmed and guilty and exhausted
what was the medication that you were
taking Abilify I take like four
medications for my mental illness
um I take umbilophile motogen buspirone
and
um sometimes Klonopin
um but with Klonopin it's kind of harder
because it's a benzodiazepine and I
actually overdosed on it because a
doctor's directions or you had me taking
four to five pills of Klonopin a night
to try and sleep to help with my
depression
and I was on that for years and you're
not supposed to do that it's supposed to
be for emergencies
and I
I was in like a really really depressive
episode I was like suicidal and the
doctor told me like oh you know what you
should do just I want you to take six
tonight so you sleep and you'll feel
better if you sleep your depression will
go down and I ended up overdosing that
night which was really really painful
and really scary but before you're on
the medications what was there anything
that you saw that triggered it the ups
and downs
um the seasons when the seasons would
change I noticed my moods would start
getting really crazy for a while
um in the summer I would be like more
manic so I was like
I started to notice like oh [ __ ] like
these some of my friends don't want to
like hang out with me right now because
oh sorry some of my friends don't want
to hang out with me because I'm like
scaring them I'm being so erratic I'm
driving like 120 on the freeway and
um it would just come randomly but
mostly during the seasons or like high
summer that's when I'd have all that
energy and all that sunlight and just
go off so
it's it's can be unpredictable sometimes
but it's it's uh mostly just a wild ride
it was the darkest thing you went
through
um
I would say shortly after I was
diagnosed I was really manic for a while
and then I went into like such a
depressive episode I had to withdraw
from my University I was at I didn't
leave my room
um I wouldn't see friends for days I
wouldn't talk to anyone I would
obsessively paint my nails
I would watch like just movies
constantly I'd go to sleep at 8am sleep
until 7 P.M walk to the store get some
food and just stay in my room the only
reason I left was just to use the
restroom other than that I didn't talk
to anybody for days and I had to like
medically withdraw from school and I had
to come back to San Diego
and I felt so defeated I felt like such
a loser that I couldn't handle doing
school it was really hard
um because I always wanted to do that
um I've had a couple like kind of
breakdowns going to the hospital was one
of them too
that was
I was like in a relationship at the time
and I just felt like my head was like
collapsing in on itself
and I just
I told my parents like I need to go to a
hospital like I can't live like this
so then they took me and um I was there
for a pretty short stay
um
but it was just I felt like what's the
point of life like why am I even here
what's the point of living with
something that will never change and
it's just gonna get worse with age
like
it felt pointless
and like
you feel upset because you're just like
I want to be able to live a Carefree
life I want to be able to go and do what
I want with friends or go on a trip and
not worry like do I have my meds do I
have contact with my doctor do I have
all the things that keep me from like
um like melting down or having like a
manic episode or a depressive episode
and it's hard but you just learn to live
with it with like I have you know I'm
lucky that I have like my family and I
have resources to like medication thanks
Medi-Cal
um so that helps but it's still
definitely like hard to go through an
experience it's exhausting
but I most of the time I try and stay
more positive
um just because like what else can you
do life is hard enough might as well try
and put a positive spin on it most days
it's got to be tough when your romantic
Partners yes
um I think that it's really important
like because I've been diagnosed it's
like my responsibility now to take care
of myself not only so I can be happy and
exist and live a normal life but also
because the people who love me and the
my friends and my family they don't
deserve to have to like run after me in
a manic episode or
you know had to pick me up every time
I'm in a depressive episode like it's I
know they'll do it because they love me
but it's not fair to them
I want to be an an equal partner I want
to be a friend who could support others
and not have all the focus on me all the
time and so I think it's like my
responsibility to take care of it so I
try and stay on top of it as much as I
can
but it has been really hard on former
partners
um I was in a really abusive
relationship with someone who has gone
through their own stuff but I was like
wildly erratic and I would go through
these skyrocketing highs and these crazy
lows
and it was just so toxic like he wasn't
a really toxic person but so was I at
the time because I was really sick
and like to this day I still feel like a
sense of guilt about it like he wasn't a
good partner but I wasn't either at that
point did he have other issues other
than bipolar did he yeah he um this was
like my first big boyfriend he had like
really bad depression
um it was like a huge narcissist too but
each of the boyfriends I've had or my
long-term relationships have had some
level of mental health issue I guess you
just seek what's familiar I guess does
being bipolar make you attracted to
people that are
who also have like mental health
challenges stable mentally
I think
I think it's just because it feels
familiar and you feel like oh this
person understands what I'm going
through we could fix each other like it
doesn't work like that but you're just
you get drawn into that because you feel
like it's familiar so I feel safe
but then it ends up not being safe and
it ends up just like snowballing and
getting worse
and that's
not fun and it's really tough
um but like thankfully with the
relationship I'm in now which I hope to
be in Forever
um I it is stable and he's like the most
stable person I've ever been with and
it's like healthy and it just it feels
really nice so like the medications help
you yeah the medication maintain that
relationship yes absolutely the
medications have really helped me
maintain this relationship on them and
I've always told them like if it ever
comes to a time where I'm scaring you or
you're really concerned for a mental
health
please tell me because I don't want to
lose this amazing person who has made me
feel like so fulfilled and has loved me
unconditionally
I don't want to lose them because I
can't
because I choose not to take care of
myself mentally
oh my God I'm getting emotional I didn't
think I would but
yeah I just really care about this
person and I want to be with them
and I'm thankful for mads because it's
made it possible to be with someone like
in a healthy way when in the past before
I found those meds that worked I was
just with people who didn't make me feel
good or I just felt like confined or
whatever else it's just
it's hard relationships are hard in
general but when either mental illness
into the mix it just makes it like a
wild ride so I've had like three big
relationships the first one was uh the
abusive one with uh depression the
second one I met in an outpatient
program
[Music]
um
he was really like withdrawn very quiet
and I almost saw it as a challenge like
I'm gonna become his friend
because I'm the kind of person who
thinks that there's no such thing as
like strangers just like friends I
haven't met yet I'm just really chatty
um
but I met him and we ended up becoming
friends and eventually we started dating
but he was schizoaffective and he had
just recently been homeless for I think
like eight or nine months in Los Angeles
San Diego like all around California
um but he was like
he was really sweet
and he cared for me immensely
um but it was he definitely wasn't
stable which was difficult and like now
looking back at I realized like wow he
really wasn't stable like I was looking
over a lot of stuff because I was like
in my own sickness at the time too
um but then what added like even more
fun to the mix was that he was like a
Hare Krishna which like he
self-describes as a cult
um I know that like the people from the
hare Christians were always really nice
to me so I don't necessarily have like
complaints about them besides some of
the restrictions but
he was like a hardcore Hare Krishna like
he would meditate for three and a half
hours a day he didn't eat mushrooms
onion garlic like this huge list of food
which drives me crazy because I'm such a
foodie
um
and then he was also like devoutly
Catholic where he would like on a
Saturday night or like on a Saturday go
to church and read like the sermon for
people
but then on Sunday go to the temple and
like do like the Mantra and the singing
and the everything else and listen to
this to the like scripture and I still
don't know how that works to the Hare
Krishna yeah it's the Hare Krishna so
Saturday Catholicism Sundays sometimes
the Catholic church and the temple
but like he always tried to explain it
to me but it never made sense to me but
he became hard Christian in the first
place because when he was homeless
he was in Venice Beach and the people
um there was a bunch of Hari krishnas
there and they met him they talked to
him and they saw he was pretty sick so
they took him like under their wing they
took him to like a farm in central
California where he worked and was able
to stay and be safe
um
so I think that's like one of the big
reasons why he was really committed to
the hare krishnas was because it kind of
saved him in a time where no one knew
where he was he wasn't he wasn't safe he
was delusional
um so like they're kind to people but
it's definitely pretty culty but he was
devoutly Catholic devoutly Hari Krishna
and he found a way to make it
work that I don't understand to this day
but he seemed
he wasn't stable but he seemed happy
like that was like his kind of way to
try and stay stable was if I meditate
for three and a half hours a day if I
don't do this this and that if I don't
eat these Foods then I should be fine
but he was still going through delusions
and he was still depressed
um so I think I was trying to be like a
Band-Aid on what he was experiencing but
he
he just didn't want like medical
intervention he wanted to do it himself
and I feel like he really
um he really missed it he really misses
out on life because
he's not getting the help that he could
get and help that he needs and he's just
like going through his existence rather
than just like enjoying life and living
and that makes me sad I don't talk to
him really
maybe once a year I'll say hi happy
birthday and it just
it hasn't
he hasn't changed much I just feel
really sad for him because I hope you
could find someone like he really loves
and be in a relationship that's healthy
and that he can do what he wants to get
married and have kids someday but
he's not like
utilizing what he has to get better
which is sad to me and like I just wish
him the best what was the craziest point
of that relationship
so he really loved me and he
he really loved me and it was really
sweet
um but he wasn't like taking care of his
mental health like he should be he
thought like using these Band-Aids on
like this broken bone was gonna work and
it things started going kind of sour
when I remember we built garden beds we
built them from scratch we
we planted this garden and it was
beautiful and we're exhausted after like
a whole day being in the sun we
we were making dinner and he was really
quiet and I was like cutting like onions
or something or I don't know whatever or
not onions he didn't eat those but
something
and I remember he was really quiet and I
asked him like hey what's up like what's
going on and he told me he's like
I just like had this like delusion in my
head or just like this vision of me like
getting that knife and like stabbing you
in the back
and I was like oh my God holy [ __ ] like
I didn't want to make him feel bad
because I knew it was involuntary but
like my stomach just like crunched up I
was so scared
um
and like he didn't tell me some stuff
after that for like a while but
probably after like five months we were
together for about two years
after about five months he would tell me
like yeah I just I had this like picture
in my head of me like shoving you to the
ground or like smacking your hand away
or like hitting you
and like I knew like okay I don't feel I
don't feel safe around this person
anymore
and he may love me as much as possible
and he may care for me and be kind but I
don't feel safe being around someone
who's like has these active thoughts of
like oh I want to stab her in the back
or I really want to punch her right now
and I just realized like I couldn't live
with having someone
envisioning mine to hurt me like that
was really
that was hard and I just knew like okay
this I can't do this anymore I need to
be someone who wants to be better or
wants to get better and who doesn't want
to scare their partner
and so then I just kind of like I
invited him over one day and I was like
torn apart because this person just like
put so much effort and love into our
relationship and I remember
telling I'm like okay I think I can't do
this anymore I'm sorry I love you so
much but I'm done with this and like he
felt so guilty for it and he felt so bad
that like his unchecked mental health
was was like in the way of him having
like his happily ever after with me and
that was hard
like sometimes I miss being able to talk
to him
um because we had like a great
friendship but like knowing that it's
still kind of unchecked for him I don't
want to
I don't want to be like that subject
again of like oh
that or that object or
I don't know what else of being like the
person he could hurt
like I'm not down with getting hurt by
someone else I already hurt myself
enough growing up and dealing with stuff
I don't need to add a physical component
to it so it was hard but I had to do
um I just had to end it this
compassionately and as lovingly as I
could and
here I am
four or five years later
still missing them sometimes but
realizing like
it's okay I and just like hoping for the
best for him and that he'll find like
whatever piece he's looking for and
whatever help he needs but until then
I'm just
doing what I do and trying my best in my
relationship now and trying to be
healthy and just
love and be kind to others so I'm trying
my best
mental illness makes relationships tough
yeah
it makes relationship's really tough
which is pretty unfortunate
um but it's just I guess the fact of
life for me
um and for everyone else who loves
mental illness and that's
that's difficult to swallow for sure
like having anxiety constantly like I do
like I have so much anxiety right now
but I just like learned to live with it
and I just try and like talk to myself
in my head and be like you know you're
gonna survive this you're okay
you are not crazy this is something very
real
um but you're gonna be okay but
sometimes it takes more than just
self-talk it takes like meds and therapy
and how old are you everything else I'm
29 29. yeah my
so I remember having my first panic
attack and like
third or fourth grade
um and I remember having this insane
panic attack not knowing what it was and
the next day when I woke up I felt like
everything going on in my body like I
have like this extreme phobia of like
getting sick
and I was just like hyper aware of
everything I'm feeling and it never
exists stopped to this day and I know
that you have like a normal awareness of
like oh my stomach kind of hurts or oh I
have a headache but I'm like my why why
is my heart going faster why is this is
that and it's just constant like I live
in this like constant state of anxiety
and fear that has like gotten stronger
as I've gotten older
now and I take like meds to like curb it
a little bit but because I'm so happy
with like my bipolar meds I don't want
to mess around with like my meds
unlike fix them or move them around more
and like be unstable for a while to get
rid of the anxiety like I could handle
the anxiety a lot more than I can the
depression
um but it's
It's Tricky I'm afraid to lose my
stability in terms of my bipolar to help
with the anxiety and I know that sounds
kind of counter-intuitive to what I'm
saying
but it's it's scary and I'm trying to
like work it out but I need more help
and it's kind of hard when like you
can't see your doctors very often and
when they give you medications that like
don't work and send you off
um so it's
yeah like taking the wrong meds could
just send you on Mania or make you super
depressed and then you have to like
start from scratch all over with the
bipolar meds and
so it's it's a little scary to do that
but I need to practice what I preach and
I need to go and get it taken care of
but I'm just trying my best right now
and
trying to
live like a happy life
um with all that's weird
business in the middle of it
are there things that you've learned
that you wish you knew when you were
younger
um it may have helped you
manage all this
I'm not sure
can you like clarify a little bit well I
mean like
it seems like you've finally figured out
at least some of the bipolar issues yeah
are there
things that you wish you knew like when
you were in your teens
that you you may have been able to
manage it better and avoid some of the
things you went through
um I think
I think if I had a way just to be like
more aware of what was going on so like
I was just acting as I was I wasn't
thinking like oh wait take a step back
look at what you're doing like kind of
like metacognitive wise
think about what you're thinking and see
like is there something weird with that
like I wish I was more aware of what I
was doing but I was just like blindly
going at whatever and just erratic and
everything else but I wish I could tell
like younger myself or like me when I
got diagnosed I felt so hopeless like
I remember my mom crying when the
doctors told her like oh yeah your
daughter's bipolar because my mom was
like really scared because like with her
family
the instability
and like I felt so guilty and I wish I
could tell my like younger self like
you're gonna be okay like this is really
scary
and I understand that but it's not your
fault
you're gonna be okay it's gonna take
some work but you have like people
around you who love you and you're not
alone in this so you're gonna be all
right over time
but like don't
don't go driving 120 miles per hour on
the freeway anymore like don't do that
at least
but um
yeah I know I I just wish I could be
like kinder to younger me
instead of being like Oh I should have
known this just be like no you know what
you're doing your best and you didn't
know
but now you do
and so it's like trying to forgive like
myself for being so hard on myself like
when I'm done growing up
like I still feel like this weird guilt
about like
I often wonder how many people did I
scare away that were friends
um like my family
like who thinks like oh she's crazy I
don't want to hang out with her or
like how many times does that happen
because of my mental illness and I like
Ponder on that a lot which is hard what
advice would you give to somebody who's
struggling with issues like what you've
described
um that is not sounded like a solution
um
I would say like first and foremost like
be kind to yourself
that's really hard
um
and I know that's not like tangible but
just be kind to yourself and try and
talk to the people around you and ask
them like
hey is there anything like kind of off
you've noticed like have I said some
things or have I done some things that
you're a little concerned about
I had a friend who told me like yeah I
stopped hanging out with you because you
were so erratic and I remember feeling
like wow I wish you had told me that
so like asking those around you who are
close to you like hey I just
I feel kind of weird I feel kind of off
I don't know why I'm doing this like
have you noticed
um because sometimes it takes like
hearing it from other people to be like
oh wow that is not good or I didn't
realize I was doing that so just be kind
to yourself and talk to those around you
and ask them
um yeah I think I think that's important
to do
Victoria what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life
[Music]
even
you fall flat on your face whether it's
mental health reasons relationship
reasons or whatever else
even when you fall flat you're still
moving forward in some way
um
progress isn't perfect
and it just takes like being kind to
yourself and others to just
keep going
and with time you'll be all right
hopefully
all right Victoria thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks and good luck
from here thank you great things have
saved a lot for you
thanks thank you